Speaker 1: h. Oh, you know what? We
have a caller from the Philippines.
CALLER from the Philippines. Welcome.
Speaker 4: Good. Good morning, David. Well,
I have to say that the Philippine election
is being chaotic and dirty because I voted
for Leni Robredo, a family man for president
and vice president. But as the votes came in,
it seems that they voted for Bongbong Marcos
and Santa Fe. Yep. And you know what they did?
They brainwash them. They are the call. They're
similar to the Republicans in the United States.
They are nothing but a fool. So my question to
you is what the return of Marcos actually affect
the relationship between the United States
and the Philippines? Because in the 1980s
it's actually been rocky and the inquiry. Aquino
came in and became president of the Philippines.
And now, with the return of Marcos, we
are on another six years of the same
old politics of dirty tricks, political dynasties
and of course, vote buying. Do you think do you
think it will embolden the Republicans in 2022?
Speaker 1: I don't know the answer to that. But
you have you by the way, I love the energy. You're
shot out of a cannon today and I love every second
of it. And I would be, too, if I saw that. The son
of a former authoritarian now is going to be the
president of my country. So I sympathize with you
completely in terms of the Biden administration.
Listen, I don't want the Biden administration
being cozy with what in all likelihood is going
to be another authoritarian Philippines regime.
So that's that in terms of Republicans, you know,
I actually am not sure the Republican I don't know
what to call it. Love for some authoritarians like
Putin for yes, Trump and Putin. I don't know
that it will translate to the Philippines
in the same way specifically because I
don't think a lot of Republicans have
any idea what's happening in the Philippines.
Speaker 4: Think I think the BBM Sartre supporters
are a cult similar to the MAGA cult, which
they will try to turn the United States into,
like us authoritarian blood democracy,
that that will destroy their reputation.
I think that now we are completely lacking stock
and I think Marcos and both, they are completely
unfit for the goals, precedent and.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Speaker 4: Precedent of the Philippines.
Speaker 1: Do you what do you plan to
do? What do you plan to do there now?
Speaker 4: There will be some uncertainty.
But one thing is for sure, David, if in any
combat of wings again in 2028 may make no
mistake. 2022 to 2028, when the feeds will be dark
and bloody, because this year will celebrate the
50th anniversary of martial law and the return of
a marcus sense of power would make the Philippines
suffer even more. Similar to what Trump and Pence
did in the United States in 2017 until 2021.
Speaker 3: Wow.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, you've said it all.
I wish you the best. And I appreciate the call.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you very much, David. And
I hope and I hope we will meet again real soon.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. What a powerful phone
call there from the Philippines where things are
getting very, very, very crazy. And we did cover
that on the bonus show earlier this week.
Complicated circumstances, that's for sure.